I mean there's so many people right now  they're not doing what they love because  they're worried about what other people  think when you're playing a different  game than everybody else  peer pressure doesn't even have a shot  on you it's tougher when you're 15 as  you're building your self-esteem and and  your foundation of your life when you're  51 or when you're 91 you're gonna be  stunned how little you care and and this  includes your parents and your siblings  and even your children this is an  intense thing this is a very intense  thing and you have to love yourself  first and feel good and complete with  yourself first I would do what I did as  a 15 year old would you start building  those skills and not listen to your  parents and not listen to your teachers  and not listen to your friends respect  it but don't let anybody anybody impose  their way on you it's you you're with  yourself and you've got to make yourself  happy first